welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
experience that everyone show on the
Internet today bringing the best guests
and the greatest stories scoops here to
the experts report here today on the
Internet today we are joined by the
probably one of the most requested
guests of all time on the history
podcast Eric Andre Triple Threat
musician stand-up comedian actor he's
got a lot of really cool projects on the
way he's got a Netflix special out right
now called legalized everything and we
have a really fun I'll be a short
conversation with him
coming up a little bit later after the
first break so I very much look forward
to that and today's episode of sponsored
by expressvpn and of course the ELA
Cline's Teddy Fresh we had a drop second
part of our June collection here which
includes patchwork bucket hats and
glorious blue cream and red bubble
graffiti shirts what is going on bubble
graffiti crewnecks we call this a
beautiful hoodie because let's face it
that's what it is it's a beautiful
hoodie you know this is a puffy paint
shirt that I think is going a little
under the radar mm-hmm because look at
the beautiful details on this puffy
paint look at that it's just like it's
so puffy pearl it's a really cool print
puffy paint yeah thank ya and of course
our hearts on my sleeve you know when
you wear your heart on your sleeve well
this is the shirt for you and it
actually looks really good on like looks
really good on you
so that's it Teddy fresh calm support
rep your nation all right now today I am
very much connected with all the Cova de
insanity that's going on we here in the
United States are yesterday we yesterday
being let's see cuz this always comes
out a day later now face the 26 so on
the 25th
we had over 41,000 cases new cases that
slammed the rock the record
so can we please get up a round of
applause for America number one baby we
were not be denied the first the first
spot I am starting to get worried that
we will never be able to leave America
or people come here oh yeah
Canada's closing their border Europe's
gonna close the border as well they
should I mean my mom has been wanting to
come here
she was planned to come right as soon as
the kovat whole thing Hey so she never
came and she really wants to see
Theodore and I was like okay after just
like craziness goes away let's make sure
you come right away but now I don't know
wine is not gonna be well we're all I
feel like in America everyone's just
given up to the point we're like well
we're just gonna have to wait for that
vaccine and I feel like a lot of
scientists and people are overly hopeful
they say oh we're gonna have a vaccine
and fall but just recall these are the
same people who were saying that this
would be gone by summer and now we're in
June we'll Falchi and a lot of health
experts a lot of scientists were saying
this is gonna be gone by summer
I guess assuming that people would
cooperate yeah they would that we would
be able to make an effort to a
collective effort yeah and then you know
pretty much every state reopened before
CDC puts out guidelines saying you have
to do all these things and you have to
be on a downward trajectory for 14 days
before you can safely reopen I think
there was three states that actually
followed the CDC guidelines for
reopening safely California wasn't one
of them because people needed to you
know go out but that the problem is
people aren't wearing masks they say
that if every single person wore masks
it would cut the transmission of the
virus down so significantly that that it
would pretty much disable the spread
we'd save a lot of lives course a lot of
lives a lot of jobs a lot of problems
everything
but we have given up so it's kind of
remarkable just watching the daily
numbers I just feel like this has got to
be the most confused country because the
Prime Minister is not wearing a mask our
presidents not wearing a mask president
the president is not wearing a mask so
yeah I have to it has to be like that is
just such a phone a wrong foundation for
everything you know you've got the
president I have to I really have to
think that the president not wearing a
mask refusing to wear a mask
touring masks factories and not wearing
masks is gonna have to go down as I mean
he's directly killing people by not
doing that it's well indirectly I guess
but like yeah I mean it's just it's and
he's the I don't understand how why
Trump is so flippin about kovat because
I feel like it's really gonna hurt his
reelection I mean even in Israel Bibi is
wearing a mask everybody's wearing a
mask how does it benefit your country to
be flippant about kovat I don't get it
he's turned it into a political issue so
that people can prove their loyalty to
Trump by refusing to wear masks and a
lot of people are doing that you know so
so we've given up I just hope that that
vaccine does come and November like
everyone's hoping but I'm afraid you
guys have to understand the vaccine has
never been developed that fast ever ever
ever ever ever ever and obviously we
have a huge global effort to do that but
I do think that that is being overly
optimistic but I pray that it's true and
then people go we'll look at the death
you know there's not that many deaths
only 500 a day but that's gonna start
going up because the deaths always trail
the new cases by two weeks make sense
right so we're gonna start seeing that
go up exponentially as well as starting
to see more and more people that I just
kind of like randomly follow on
Instagram and stuff saying that they got
the virus
right I saw a post on Twitter she's like
I have autoimmune disease I've done
everything right I social distance I
wear a mask I clean everything off and
I've got covered really yeah and then
you've got even people so far as down as
Joe Rogan who you who like you know I
respect the man but he saw like Bill
burr had this viral moment when he
goofed on Joe Rogan for saying don't you
think wearing a mask makes you a [ __ ]
or something to that effect and I mean
when you when you've got the president
down to Joe Rogan who wields a lot of
influence like the second president he's
the president and I heard a really funny
analogy they say Joe Rogan is like the
Gwyneth Paltrow of broths he's got like
the goop the on it is his goop hello
Brogan yeah exactly but so like you know
and I really take cross with this whole
notion that wearing a mess makes you a
[ __ ] you have to understand wearing a
mask doesn't even protect you it
protects other people what about that is
a bit as being a bit it's just I don't
know what's so hard to understand if you
wear it you're protecting others because
you can have no symptoms and still carry
the virus and still give it to other
people what's so hard to understand it's
like so I think people I think people
think they wear the mask to protect
themselves but by having people said it
like a million times by now yeah
explaining how it catches your
respiratory droplets I was listening to
somebody talk about the other day he
says it was dr. foutch he's a reputable
guy the mask catches 90% of your
respiratory droplets and then you need a
certain amount of virus to get infected
and so the amount that it cuts down
makes it virtually impossible to
transmit the disease unless you're in
like a really small room with bad
circulation with that person for a while
if you're outside with masks it's almost
impossible to transmit the virus
right another thing about the virus is
that that I learned is that it really
doesn't transfer from surfaces it's all
from people to people yes exactly so the
whole surface thing like I stopped
sanitizing my groceries and stuff goes
like such a [ __ ] slab - yes so so
it's really all about the respiratory
droplets about the mask and washing your
hands and washing your hands always is
great so it's about it's really happens
when you breathe in other people's
droplets mists whatever you know that's
why the most dangerous environment is
like a small air-conditioned room much
like this one stay away from me because
then the air circulates and everybody
gets sick but anyway how do we get on
this yeah it's just incredible and
somehow dumbfounded that the stock
market do the stock market is completely
uncoupled from reality stock market is
like a big troll they go yesterday
they're like the biggest day single day
of new covent infections over 41,000 and
the stock market today is up 2% it's a
coup is [ __ ] investing the stock
market on that news I don't get it I
don't get it I don't like it I keep
saying it's almost like a Bitcoin crazy
everyone thinks they're a day trader now
I've heard several people tell me that
their day traders on ironically I'm like
Newton everybody's a day trader in a
bull market
just wait till [ __ ] hits the fan we'll
see how much of a day trader you are
it's I don't understand our economy I
don't understand I don't understand it
it's crazy
anyways my birthday this week thank you
here long yeah birthday you treated me
very well I'm like I'm 35 years old yeah
35 I'm not like depressed about it
actually I usually get to press my
birthday but I actually wasn't depressed
this time because we got a little
Theodore yeah Theatre is a great one I
mean there's a lot of love in our house
I feel very I do feel very happy in our
home with our doggies and our kid so
cute yeah he's such a sweetheart
we haven't done a theater update in a
long time so a little update mm-hmm
he's obsessed with tractors track trying
there's a new dachshund trust that's
always says any kind of whispers ooh so
cute he goes yeah and he thinks he
thinks anything with wheels is a track
and he started pointing and goes this so
it goes anything with wheels like for
example we there was a cooler we were
doing a photo shoot and the cooler had
wheels he goes tractor we're like well
close but he's walking now like fully
walking he's starting to talk he just
got his first haircut he looks so cute
he loves his books I got him like a
tractor book with all the different
kinds of trucks and tractors mm-hmm and
he just loves it it's so funny oh my god
dude
I had like a heart attack yesterday he
face-planted on the tiles and I got so I
got so distraught because he slammed his
head on the ground
and you can hear it was like dude then
he starts crying and he had nose on it
he had blood on his lip and coming out
of his nose and I was like oh my god
I get so nervous I was like he's got
brain damage he broke something he's
never gonna be the same he's got brain
damage he's never gonna be same I just
real
we just ruined his life the thumb
pressure
dude I felt so distraught it really
wasn't that bad though no he was fine
but I just like I was so distraught I
felt so bad for him but he was totally
fine in like five minutes but he had
blood coming out of his little nose I
mean that was like a door or a thick
yeah anyway had a good birthday
it was very nice I'm 35 years old and uh
I feel okay about it you know it's all
right it'll be worse it could be 40 40s
[ __ ] weird yeah 40s gonna be weird
dude that's like oh dude you wanted
those people I'm dead bro you want what
people wanted those people that are 40 I
don't know dose like that this person
like those people oh you're one of those
people yeah yeah yeah you're an old
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
anyone over 40 is is there not a cool
90s kid they're like a piece of [ __ ]
boomer it's like the kid from a
different school kind of thing I want to
be a piece I already am a piece of [ __ ]
boomer let's be honest speaking of
wearing masks I love this video there's
a whole new breed of people who refuse
to wear masks I've thought about this
okay you know how we were all making fun
of social justice warriors like three
four years ago I submit to you here
today that these people are the new
social justice warriors they have the
same energy the same vibe and it's just
a [ __ ] mask it's just a mask watch
this guy he's well he's willing to throw
a life and I'm at Walmart
[Music]
well y'all will morning guys it's
Walmart dog you don't have a [ __ ]
god-given right to be in Walmart oh I
thought there was more I don't know more
I think this is a short version like he
teach art wait can you find a longer
version because he charges in there yeah
there was another that setting old men
oh yeah no I think you would know better
no it's his god-given right you look to
just shop him Walmart without a mask
that's what they think life liberty and
the pursuit of not wearing a mask the
pursuit of joy there was another thing i
retweeted which I'll pull up here did I
get off on these kinds of tweets this
this to me is is my favorite thing right
now she goes this is on Facebook of
course me wearing no mask and going the
wrong way down every aisle and Walmart
but see see this this rude and I'm just
gonna say this and forgive me [ __ ] I'm
forgiven because she this is this is
just a cruel she ever either from
ignorance or just flippant cruelty you
walking down Walmart aisles without a
mask you are not helping yourself you're
risking the people around you that old
Nana reaching up for jello on the top
shelf is gonna drop dead because of your
dumb [ __ ] ass okay well anyway a
couple days later she writes as of today
I was informed I tested positive for
coven 19 if I've been in contact with
anyone lately please go get tested [ __ ]
you [ __ ] right now my own system are
dizzy spells dry throat and cough which
I thought were just allergies please
keep my family and your prayers I'm not
praying for you as I have got a lot of
kids I have a lot of kids so we're going
to say how many kids specifically yeah
did you forget the number
how many kids like it's less words to
just say how many kids you have just one
digit I'm assuming who I am worried
about most especially my two month old
well maybe you should have [ __ ] taken
a more seriously dumb-dumb would you
pray for her you'll pray no mask no
prayers that's my policy
mmm what about thoughts will you think
about her I just did I guess I'll think
about her but bad thoughts is it rude to
call a female person a [ __ ] I feel like
it I think so yeah but the thing is like
so here's where eyes what's the
equivalent for a guy you could call him
I think it's the equivalent is his
[ __ ] or butt but not really because
there's a sexist connotation a bit yeah
but here's where I draw the line if
you're just like Hadley referring to a
female as a [ __ ] that's just sweet well
we used to all do that I feel like an
and I've stopped doing that and I catch
myself when I do it but I'm like wow
this girl this woman is a real [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that woman's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
- like flaunt that she's cruising around
aisles of Walmart without a mask proud
of it like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you know what
I mean and I don't like saying [ __ ]
right I don't like calling don't like it
and don't like it no I don't like it
either but like what do you call that
what do you call that psycho I said I
said psycho all the time lately I
probably need more words in my
vocabulary like dude if you're gonna
call any woman a [ __ ] it's her I think
but there's a lot of guys doing that - I
mean if you call a guy [ __ ] it's pretty
insulting - cuz it damask you lights
them I like calling guys a [ __ ] yeah so
then I should be able to call a female a
bit but like I
have to really use you can't just use
that yeah like if I called you a [ __ ]
that's like fool not I would never do
you can yeah I'm gonna do that
it's not funny Oh
keemstar has something to say opinion on
this conversation
thank you very much keep starting anyone
else I think everyone agrees with me
right what that it's that you shouldn't
but y'all women [ __ ] yeah but she's a
[ __ ] yeah I mean I I've lately I find
myself going to the more than the [ __ ]
oh well that's way more insulting you
know I feel like it's shifting I don't
know because the rest of the
english-speaking world too is is fairly
casual and I gotta stop you if you call
a female the c-word we can't even say
that dan you're gonna have to you're
gonna have to believe that because
YouTube D monetizes our whole hey they
dance yeah I mean I'm gonna beep that
one too but here's the thing you can't
even you can't even bleep it
you understand cuz if they know what
you're saying you can't even think it
yeah it they hold I learned this first
of all from YouTube and I was like what
but they hold the c-word in the same
esteem as the n-word they consider a
hate word I may have no idea what I'm
saying because it's not my first
language but I kind of find it less
offensive in a way it's not why if you
call a female the c-word that's the
worst well you clearly sang it in a
hatred tone of course you're like trying
to offend anyway right but there is
something about saying [ __ ] from a
guide that kind of comes off in a wrong
way for me it's like if I was mad at a
female and I called her this I think
they're both equally offensive if you're
mad if you're saying it out of a place
of anger they're both really offensive
okay yeah
they're both bad but for some reason
YouTube was like oh to see words like
the n-word for women I was like really I
agree I think the see where it is
harsher
the c-word it is so hard to see where it
is like more funny for some reason yeah
well in England they use it very
colloquial colloquially in Australia the
whole in we're the only ones that take
offense to it because Americans
we're Puritan weirdos but in England in
England if you call a woman a see where
do you probably she probably won't be
what's not I don't think it's even that
and the it's not that gendered in the
rest of the world either the guys call
other guys that all the time too you
know I mean like it doesn't I don't know
it's a weird thing I don't know why it's
the fact that there's a gender to but
she was a [ __ ] let's be clear that
woman's a bit I think she's a c-word oh
yeah I mean she might even go I think we
all think she's a C word basically but I
if I if you're saying I can't call her
[ __ ] then I definitely you can call her
a C word then I could definitely call
her a [ __ ] I guess definitely you have
to listen to what you're saying words
matter
alright you're gonna have to do a lot of
editing there make that work you know ja
Rule was in a commercial charles
desperate forget what I guess our rule
think about this right so ja rule is
desperate for gigs after the fire
festival apparently I don't know what's
the source on this but they say he was
paid in a ziplock bag of looks like that
would be the kind of thing yeah well how
much more can you get paid oh well let's
watch it first and then I'll give you
some more context you have context I do
have some context but it will take away
from the funny so let's just watch
[Music]
you haven't late your life so good
[Music]
Peter's Peter top priest Oh Peter
they got everything I'm gonna just give
you a rundown of some of my favorite
they got that doesn't know what to xik
is gonna know soup I'm telling you come
on down to pop Christo
so what you working with
pop or so am i doing hey hey
[Music]
so what's the context so now so it's
what was that
Jarl Oh what is it then there's a
difference look good yeah it's um is for
a reality show called celebrity show off
where show where stars compete with each
other to create compelling content and
in order to attract YouTube viewers
that's your right
I said why they want to tell you said he
made them and then I'll make it even
less funny for you ja Rule said he made
the video with hopes of helping a small
business amid the Koba 19 pandemic I
wonder if these guys getting orders are
you telling me he was not paid and a
ziplock bag I do not believe I love that
guys tweet but no I don't think it's on
Pico we should go
if commercials were just like that on TV
that'd be way better so can i order do
they deliver to this it's a little too
far yeah it's what it does draw roll
really believe what he said that doesn't
sound good but does he think that was it
false advertising though but there said
the food was good or was it no okay no
it's not but it's the food good actually
it doesn't sound good I don't know yeah
I don't know what to think about it then
these are like
that's what Vin Diesel tells the gyro
before he takes a bite this is this is
Vin Diesel seconds before biting into
the gyro it's probably girl this is Vin
Diesel after his first bite of gyro this
is Kim sir after taking one bite of gyro
garbage isn't like this is him after
three bites of gyro garbage you really
crossed the line anyway how much time we
got
we're about 28 minutes into the show you
know you guys may have heard is a big
story jenna Marbles is she's cancelled
herself she's leaving YouTube she's
gotten a lot of [ __ ] from people over
the years and she's just I guess made in
a final apology video and said she's
stepping away from her channel in a
video called a message and it's been all
the talk of the town really I think it's
been really hard for everyone to watch
the video and to see her be so hard the
first two things that I would like to
address is the fact that there are
people that were offended that I did
blackface as Nicki Minaj in 2011 and
I'll show you the clip incredibly crazy
and embarrassing this is private it has
been private for quite some time but it
looks like this you know look I'm not
the person who say what blackface is OK
it not but I do wonder if there's a
difference like Jimmy Kimmel recently
got in trouble Jimmy Kimmel Karl Malone
I don't know if he got in trouble people
are trying to expose expose them for
doing blackface
and then there was the man shot and he
used to do bits where he would like
black body but he used to always do
these bits about Carl Malone because
he's such a character and whole like et
call or read all TV about white people
getting deducted by alien stick I don't
know I don't know if the times just
changed upon us I guess you wouldn't do
that to all the times I've definitely
changed yeah no one is doing this but I
think it's kind of you can't really go
back in time this far and then like
apply today's standards like think about
that this was on Comedy Central
like they have censors and standards and
practices and the people who run that
department saw this who are the Eagles
they [ __ ] and Nick everything in the ass
right they don't let anything slip by
and they saw this and thought that was
okay I'm not saying it's okay now but at
the time the people who were paid to be
super critical of anything that could be
controversial greenlit this sketch and I
think that just goes to show that you
can't go back in time like god one was
one was a show even I mean [ __ ]
twenty years ago probably right yeah man
show was like definitely opening an
interesting conversation to what
what should still leave out there though
because when YouTube the weird thing is
that it's always available for you to
watch but she did private yes video yeah
so I mean I've done and said really
cringey [ __ ] my early career that I've
private 'add you know I think everybody
has like everyone is like the society as
a whole is growing over the years and
understanding of what's okay and what's
not okay and these are just like the
these are just little pieces of part of
what was okay at that time but it's also
kind of like a reminder that how things
have changed like I would never see this
today you know but uh but to me it's
clear that he's not like when you say
blackface you or your what the original
black faces when white people would
black people and color their face black
because black people weren't accepted to
play themselves in theater because
people were so racist but like when I
look at what he's doing here I don't see
a dude who's really doing that
I think he's doing an impression but
again I'm not the person to to say if
this is okay or not you know I could see
why people would be I mean he doesn't
look can he do it I don't know I I
frankly I don't know I'm conflicted on
it I guess but anyway this whole thing
like is he wearing like a whole rubber
suit like he looks [ __ ] crazy yeah I
know I mean it's like so beyond why face
what if swat-bots is armed he's
committed to the is it like a whole
rubber suit cuz like look at how buff
his arms around right that could be at
his neck used to watch the show yeah I
never liked it I like that one kid they
had like this one kid they would tell
what to do on the street this
twelve-year-old kid with the earpiece in
and he would like hit oh they would like
feed him lines or whatever yeah remember
I like that but hey whatever so so this
is kind of what's happening to Jenna
even though she already she had private
did that video years ago though right
like this isn't in reaction and it's
from 2011 I think she's being so hard on
herself but I understand people keep
bringing it up and bringing it up as
like what can you do you know but I
think all of us who have been on the
internet that long who has not among us
over a 10-year career on YouTube done or
said something that by today's standard
Willa Coralville nobody I mean nobody
except keemstar he's the one person with
clean hands he has never said or done
anything offensive garbage but I just
you know it's a really tough
conversation I there's it's been she's
being super responsible and she clearly
wants to do the right thing yeah and I
think that's really
really good of her but I do think she it
seems like she's still harsh on herself
all of her new content for years nothing
like that old stuff I have to say that
I've always had a lot of respect for
Jenna because for the past several years
she's been making content that at the
expense of nobody which is kind of an
outlier on YouTube right the trend on
YouTube for the past several years is
like talking about this talking about
this person and she's actually out there
doing original content and so I've
always thought like hey that that's
really cool that she's doing that here's
another one from her past that I guess
people will keep bringing up the next
thing that I want to address this is
also from 2011 a bad year for me in
judgment apparently same year this video
was called bounce that dick this has
also been made private I don't want to
offend anyone I'm not interested in it
I'm not interested in making anyone feel
bad in case you haven't noticed here's
the clip I'll play it for you here hold
on let me remind you so as you can see I
said hey ching chong Ling Wong shake
your King Kong ding dong that was racist
I'm bad at rap songs I mean it's just a
goof
you know
um yeah I understand her obviously
doesn't want to be a part of something
that might insult someone also I guess
he doesn't want people to look at that
and then like think like oh I can do
that today yeah she [ __ ] she misused to
make videos slut-shaming girls she says
for sleeping around because about what
girls do what guys do she says she
doesn't like gender identity jokes yada
yada yada
she's being very responsible very on
herself I think she's a great person I
think she makes great content I have a
lot of respect for her and I'm very sad
that she's being so hard on herself and
that there's these little [ __ ] trolls
on the internet too and I have to tell
you the people who bring this [ __ ] up
repeatedly over and over again are the
same these people don't care about being
offended by it they really I feel like
the people who bring this up are just
trying to make a point look you're a
[ __ ] hypocrite because you did this
ten years ago and so now you can never
address this in fact it's a shame
because there are real movements right
now that are happening for good reasons
that should be happening and changes
that are good and then there's like the
extreme like this where I don't know
like yeah those videos were wrong and
she already knew that and she already
private to them and she already has
moved on from this content she doesn't
make this today so I think she is
allowed to grow she's clearly made a
meaningful change in her life like
there's no resemblance of that old
content for several years going so you
have to give someone the benefit of the
doubt at a certain point but like I said
the people who anyway I don't want to
get theirs this next week I have a lot
more to talk about but anyway I go I
give my thoughts and my prayers go out
to jenna Marbles who's great and I wish
her all the best and with that being
said let's throw it to a quick break
and when we come back we will interview
the great heir Andre to celebrate the
release of his new comedy special on
Netflix called legalize everything it's
a short interview he was limited on time
today but we make the best of it so
let's uh let's see you guys in a little
bit and we'll see there I know most of
you are probably thinking why don't you
use incognito mode well let me tell you
something incognito mode does not hide
your activity it doesn't matter what
mode you use or how many times you clear
your browser history your internet
service provider can see every single
disgusting raunchy [ __ ] up filthy
rotten thing you've done you sick [ __ ]
that's why even when I'm at home I never
go online without using expressvpn it
doesn't matter if you get your internet
from Verizon or Comcast ISPs in the u.s.
can legally sell your information to ad
companies whoa I didn't know that that's
crazy
expressvpn is an app that reroutes your
internet connection through their secure
servers so that your ISP can't see the
sites you visit expressvpn also keeps
all your information secure by
encrypting 100% of your data with the
most powerful encryption available most
of the time I don't even realize I have
expressed VPN turned on and it runs
seamlessly in the background and it's
just so easy to use all you have to do
is tap one button and boom you are
protected expressvpn is available on all
your devices phones computers and even
your Smart TV so there is no excuse for
you not to be using it protect your
online activity today with the VPN rated
number 1 by C net and wired visit our
exclusive link at expressvpn comm /h 3
and you get an extra 3 months for free
with a one-year package that's expr e SS
VPN dot-com / h3 expressvpn dot-com / h3
to learn more
welcome everybody Eric Andre here to
celebrate among many other things to
legalize everything available right
freaking now on Netflix and I
congratulate you on an excellent and a
really fun stand up I'd you is this your
first this is your first I didn't even
know you did stand up to be quite frank
so I was very impressed I did it I done
it longer than anything else I've been
doing it 17 years this is my most
special well you were I thought it was
fantastic
and and prophetic as well I know we
filmed it in October and somehow more
relevant now than when we when we taped
yeah yeah you uh you have a bit where
you are making fun of the show cops
which is now cancelled yes and we
released the clip I think the day or day
after it was canceled so how do you feel
about that do you feel that uh that's
perfect timing I mean the timing is
impeccable do you I feel like cops maybe
is a show they shouldn't probably have
ever existed now that I'm thinking about
it they're probably not just glorifying
cops like but in the 80s and 90s I did
watch it as a kid I did too yeah I was
glued to it it was fascinating fascistic
so you have you have releases special at
a time when people were allowed to
gather it's hard to miss the fact that
there's people gathered you just barely
hit that co vid you are you hit you
can't before Govan no I'm not articulate
that's where you're wrong we filmed it a
week ago everyone you were the last one
to make a special the last the last
special it is the final special so
what's your life post covered what is it
what is Erica Cove it ain't over brother
post covert I mean Co vid is here but
what's your life like now dope is here
to stay
I'm going a little stir-crazy but uh
Kenny should accomplish I was
drinking a lot and getting ahead take a
month off of drinking myself a little
too much self-medicating don't have any
bats in the cave any boogers
no sir no you look good you look
beautiful Eve do you trim your nose
hairs I don't see any no Wow you want
less I'm I'm hashtag blessed yeah see if
I give you that similar view you would
not be huh do it not be both of your
both of your eye lines are so like what
are you guys looking at we have a
television where we can see you
wow you're watching cops I'm watching
crops
I'm not rotated videos I'm gonna look at
the camera yes so yes really happy you
don't have to I'm just roasting you you
can look and look at where whatever your
heart desires it just as a so what's
what's going on how are you I will spare
you that we had yesterday 41,000 new
cases of kovat so we are number one
congratulations I think it's worth
celebrating USA and we also had 2,500
deaths yesterday to which I want to say
I my only regret is that if we would
have stopped testing earlier we could
have saved those poor lives
yep did you have gray hair before you
got a salt and pepper you know Silver
Fox thing going on no yeah no it's a cut
it's the co vid oh it's coursing through
your veins yeah yeah oh I like I like it
you look mature
well thank you what do you said you
match and you any and you match your
shirt actually I individually dye
specific hairs to match the ensemble
that I am wearing for the day that's
have you seen this I got shot I can't
show this to you but I'll describe it to
you it's the most incredible thing I've
ever seen you can't spell American dream
without Eric Andre in the middle goddamn
right my parents plan that they're very
patriotic how
no that's not that's just total
happenstance what's the first time you
realize that I mean nothing terrible I
saw that on Twitter the others are like
four or five years ago yeah it's not
that thing ever it's right there in the
middle so there you go
[Music]
what are we gonna do we're gonna
legalize everything is that the issue
today yeah [ __ ] it
Yolo anarchy in the streets though but I
think there's something to that I think
we do need to legalize all the drugs I
mean legalize everything is
tongue-in-cheek right I don't mean
legalize murder no not murder but yeah
legalize legalize all non-violent
consensual adult activities right things
that bring things that bring adults joy
in moderation and used responsibly and
not abused should be illegal and making
them an illegal doesn't make the demand
for them go away
no it just pushes them to the
underground where they are put in the
hands of violent people so yeah that's
that's bored though you have stabbed it
you have a wonderful anecdotes about
prostitutes LSD and everything else
really
MDMA cocaine I think we should legalize
all of it and I'd like and I'd like to
know and I'd like to do all of it with
you okay sounds good let go half see
something oh yeah sounds great so what
else is going on you you've finished
you've accomplished the stand-up we've
got Eric Andre coming up the new season
is this year it was been released is
that right yeah that's exciting season 4
season 5 going out this year we got my
movie coming out on Netflix this year
very exciting stuff the movie by the way
which I've been looking forward to you I
can't watch it anywhere right I was
trying to find it cuz you've got an hour
yet Oh cuz it said Jeff it was it was
gonna come in April and then kovat
happened it was gonna be released
theatrically in April we're gonna
premiere it South by Southwest released
theatrically then kovat hit and all came
crashing down but the net
thought they loved loved thank God so
you got a Netflix deal you got did they
buy your soul cuz you got the they got
the stand up they got hope so my souls
for sale that's great
I that's a great place to have your
movie I can't wait to watch it it looks
like because I saw the trailer and it
said it came out in April or something I
was like why the [ __ ] haven't I heard of
this no it was supposed to be released
theatrically but they no mo movie date
is left yeah so are they're not open or
someone weren't open or you got a six
six feet from your grandpa at the movie
theater it's all couples it's complex so
the movie is kind of like a bad grandma
s you you mind if I eat up some tacos go
for it do you think is that okay
my girlfriend me just microwave these
leftover tacos oh you microwave your
leftovers the tacos I do not like to eat
them cold we're getting a little house
too let me see your girlfriend oh she's
very shy do you want to be on camera
babe that's a hard no well let's see the
doctor
well can we keep the talk she's like
running away from the camera she's not
holding her hostage it's an Ariel Castro
sir
so tell me about the movie because it
looks fantastic
so yes it is it is a bad grandpa kind of
thing is yes narrative hidden-camera we
made it with the guy that directed bad
grandpa all the man did become
co-created Jaka so he was our mentor our
Shepherd through the projects and it is
a narrative hidden camera prank movie so
every single scene as they get in camera
prank but it pushes a story forward a la
Borat
Bruno bad grandpa kind of thing so next
amazing I always wonder why I was
watching the trailer and sometimes you
do things that are might provoke a
response from people that don't know a
violent response for people that don't
know you're pranking them does that ever
happen we got a knife pulled out on this
day one of shooting and rang up with the
movie oh yeah but because rut we did it
we did a prank you know we don't think
any reactions it's all real reactions
hidden camera we did a prank where me
and rel our characters get their penis
is stuck in a Chinese finger trap we're
running and we're running all over town
with her dicks no Chinese finger trap
begging people to help pull us out of
this thing we're in pain or in agony we
went to the hood wasn't the real [ __ ] or
was it a stunt [ __ ] it was a stunt [ __ ]
it was just like prosthetic [ __ ] so that
we were able to stretch it like yeah so
so our [ __ ] are stuck in this thing but
they look hyper-realistic so our [ __ ]
are stuck in this thing we're stretching
back before they're begging people to
get us out cut us out
we're in agony we're ant we went to the
hood we went into this like hood ass
barber shop this dude saw our dick stuck
in a Chinese finger trap we begged him
we're like excuse me mr. barber can we
borrow your scissors and he like what
bad he was like oh and he went look for
his gun he couldn't find his gun grabbed
a knife and started chasing us out and
we could barely run in this place like
cop-con peace joined at the [ __ ] and
we're running for our lives as guys
chasing us with a knife the thing the
dicks snap Relic rolls on the ground
like under a parked car I run for my
life
security jumps out my safe word is
popcorn so I'm like I'm trying to yell
popcorn
security but I had so much adrenaline I
just started saying the word goosebumps
how about goosebumps goosebumps
goosebumps and up goosebumps goosebumps
because Security's like goosebumps a
popcorn security jobs grabs the guy
we're like it's a hidden camera prank we
revealed the cameras and then he looks
around and we ask him to sign a release
for him yeah then he goes oh man y'all
are hilarious what's this [ __ ] about and
then and then he was like I want to do
these frags in this neighborhood and
then rel was like I want to quit I have
kids I don't want to risk my life for
this [ __ ] movie hmm
he calls Tiffany Haddish because they're
good friends he's like Eric Andre's
gonna get me killed in his new movie
this guy blew a weapon on us like he's
like shoot he's the Klimt and she's
dying laughing
she called me later that day and we just
had the woman that played rails sister
just dropped out she couldn't do the
movie so we had an opening in our cast
Tiffany called me later that night
Yoshio you must got real killed filming
your movie because it yeah I felt
embarrassed and she goes no I want to be
in your movie that sounds awesome I love
doing this Frank [ __ ] I was like what
it's a short movie star Tiffany Haddish
you got the job so that's that's kind of
like although we almost died to God as
Tiffany Haddish to plan the movie I'm
surprised that his impulse wasn't to
help you guys but to kill two poor men
with their penises of stuff G well we
look like eccentric german porn stars
like check out on worldly delights
teratogen Pinay and this guy is like
I've seen too much [ __ ] let's see what
you got
what are we in here oh yeah what kind
what kind of protein you got on there
mule semen no check it was hard to tell
it's very saucy so Bernie you you are a
starch Bernie supporter which all of us
here raise art you say start staunch
staunch pasta yeah how are we feeling
about Joe Biden are we are we lucky Joe
Biden sloppy joe Trump yeah yes bill Joe
gotta jump through the door man I don't
know about you but I'm tired of old all
these old [ __ ] running because
Trump is old as [ __ ] - how old is he
he's like 75 he's decrepit it's rumored
he wears two pens he wears lips
because he feels short he spray tans he
has a comb-over the guys like accident
he saw what he really looked like his
fat all right hey Pitt pasty bald yeah
lopsided legs like the decrepit old man
that he's to be ageist
but he's falling apart and he eats like
KFC and drinks like 12 diet cokes today
yeah I wonder how this you know
sometimes I'll drink two diet cokes and
I'm feel like I'm dying I go by
and it's incredible to drink that many
diet cokes oh my I almost am impressed
by that at the eye I wonder what is the
real reason Trump doesn't wear masks
people say it's a political ploy I think
he just doesn't want to I swear to God I
think he has a spray tan or makeup that
he doesn't want to rub off his face
might be a couple couple of those things
did you did you mark March with black
lives matter yeah well people wearing
masks I feel like whenever I saw yep
they're all wearing masks but there's a
guy had like a giant economy Costco
thing of hand sanitizer that's what's up
that's passing it out to all the people
like I got handsome those other people
were passing on bottled water
that's nice really like you saw like a
sense of community in unity that I
haven't really experienced my whole life
hmm
it's a very diverse crowd all Millennial
like Mary Lou youth-oriented I was like
very proud of my generation yeah yeah I
was really cool to see and there's been
a real change being made it's like
actually I think I'm hoping that we're
like at a tipping point we were about to
steer the ship like back on course
against hatred and nationalism and
bigotry I feel that too I think I almost
thought we were hopeless for a minute
but I was really impressed by the
turnout I feel like if there was no
kovat the turnout would have been like
even crazier you know no I actually
think that quarantine made people so
stir-crazy and people can't work right
now so they can focus on civil rights
issues and they're dying to know their
house and be part of community I think
it actually weirdly helped I'm super
waiting yeah because I noticed there's
this new thing in the media now as kovat
is surging out of control that now it's
the it the whole fault
is just the protesters and not Florida
that never shut down and people have
been like chilling in malls and hookah
shops yeah I think any any politician
will take any situation and use it for
the political advantage what the [ __ ] is
a else is good dude how much man I'm to
the month off and drinking but I'm gonna
drink this weekend make them cocktail
what are you thinking
I'm gonna make a hurricane I'm gonna
make a pina colada
the wrong guy you're planning ahead
mm-hmm little math um I got a couple new
cocktail cookbooks some really kind of
fancier more exotic stuff swill Tiki
stuff some tequila we sell my secret
ingredient in cocktails crush up a
little vicodin that makes a [ __ ] that
makes that cocktail two for one
I can't please no I'm just kidding I put
cocaine on my guns but celebrating just
the release of the special yeah
celebrating this summer I did a little I
got a I got a new jacuzzi so I'm gonna
mmm hop in the coos drinks and drink
some frosted drinks I'm making frozen
Palomas I got a blender get a can of
squirt to us tequila 3/4 out lime juice
maybe a little essence of grapefruit but
you get that from the squirt put in a
blender with pebble ice frozen frozen
Palomas all weekend really easy to make
delicious bore out squirt two ounce
tequila 3/4 ounce Zac write that down
yeah we'll drink blender and then but
break up your ice make your ice small
before you put it in the blender so you
get that perfect slushy consistency if
you put in big cubes it's gonna not be
consistent like a good consistency you
like slushy consistency right Zac you
writing all this yes if you think if you
don't want to do it with squirt if you
want a little bit healthier options you
could do one and a quarter ounce
grapefruit juice 3 3/4 lime 2 ounce
tequila slap some basil put in some
basil and muddle it put in a gob a 3/4
ounce of agave muddle it and yeah and
then put and then put a little topo
Chico or like a club soda video me gwah
put that on top so you get that you get
that sparkly that you got from the
squirt if you don't want to do soda
well congratulations I can see you're
very much looking forward to getting the
sauce on your lips I am salivating yeah
you make your also interestingly a
Jewish you refer to yourself as a Jewish
black man Cassius Oh ash you so your
your your your bluish do you feel that
you are almost the perfect enemy of the
Klan I feel like the Klan your enemy
number one you've got all the things
they dislike do you feel more
discriminate do you feel more hated as a
black man or a Jewish man well I think
like none of the clans hatred for me can
out match my self-loathing for myself
right there they're like child's play
yeah talk to my therapist oh you gotta
show up we be is that right yeah but we
can't film it because the quarantine so
you kind of have a show on query kwibi
kwibi
that's a comic you said qui bees a
starch you say you take liberties with
the language in a way I've never seen
before
qui be well to be frank nobody really
knows what kwibi is nobody knows what
starch is but we're yeah we know it yeah
that's true
quit quit Queenie or kwibi kwibi me what
hey what's the deal right what is the
deal with kwibi do you uh find this
whole thing come strange I mean we've
been talking about it apparently they've
spent half a billion on advertising and
I still don't know who they are what the
motive is they law they launched it a
tough time they watched right - right
quarantine started isn't that good for a
streaming service
yeah but they're like they were only
streaming on iPhones and they were meant
to be watched while you travel nobody
that while you're traveling to work
because it's like all quick bytes it's
like 5 minute 10 minute shows but
nobody's traveling to work you know no
he's on
for the subway you know so it's it's a
it's a grind everybody that's putting
out projects or add stuff like that was
coming out right now is struggling and
having to like readjust to write news
probably not gonna happen for a while
yeah I'm glad I got all my touring on my
system last year I was gonna tour Gondry
show live at the end of this year but I
think I have to wait till next year yeah
who knows at this point yeah I don't
know I don't know i really did with our
taxi we are on fire the USA is crushing
it on kovat I look forward to the
numbers every day at this point it's
just kind of like a morbid fascination
because it's just it's exponential now
and we are killing it yeah Japan didn't
shut down and they have little to no
coke there yes like way more hygienic
than us and they were masks that's don't
shake hands they bow yeah just at the
wear mask
be smart be hygienic and no more
handshakes handshakes are over every
time we leave the house I still see
people without a mask laughing all the
time yeah well it's a cultural thing you
really just really highlighted the
culture of each country like u.s. Mexico
and Brazil are like no masks and then
the president of Brazil covet and he was
in ICU Mexico is rampant in Mexico it's
rampant in the United States the United
States we're cowboy culture so we're
like yeah you ain't gonna tell me to
wear a mask but Japan is like we're
obedient we're hygienic all right we got
to go to work we're gonna continue they
didn't shut down their businesses they
didn't shut down their economy their
economy is fine and their kovin
Australia is doing well too but
Australia has the benefit of being
remote and underpopulated same wind
easier but they're also much cleaner
than us there's I am proud of those
countries there's not like pollution and
garbage everywhere
we're like scum bags these Hot Cheetos
I see you know but you are you you do
seem very politically active what is
what is what is the some some things
that you are most passionate about the
things we need to change here in this
America the number one thing is global
warming because if you cook the earth or
we're all gonna die that no political
opinion matters yeah there's no vetch
there's no vegetation if there's no
vegetables and no animals there's no
food and then we die how do we fix that
do we I think we just need our old
politicians to die because they just
don't care about it yeah there's volkova
factory fun fact factory farms and
fossil fuel maybe Cove it's a good thing
kill everybody else kill all those yeah
really really really all of humanity
should probably die and we just give the
planet back to the animals yeah but
that's just me you are the creator of
prostate karaoke are you not I am the
creator I'm glad I am yes I'm a fan of
Howard Stern and I have to applaud you
for being the genesis of some of the
best sound bites on that show thank you
very much and they're very very sweet to
me shout out to the Benji screams
screaming and terror when his when it
gets fingers up his asses truly yeah
he's emotional guy
very dramatic how old are you are you
getting routine prostate checks yet or
is that that's not yeah that was the
first one he said my prostate was very
healthy but I'm under 40 I guess once
I'm 40 I'm afraid my prostate probably
has a little growth because when I pee I
get a lot of dribble sometimes I have to
rush a bit blood comes out blood does
come out of the the one time one time I
got my prostate checked and I looked you
know I felt it go away and look behind
me and both of the doctors hands were in
the air did Wow
that was it in uh was it in a doctor's
room or was it uh it
in an alleyway yeah that explains that
yeah for sure
it was in an alleyway I was in Moscow
mm-hmm you show your dick a lot how does
how does that get the penis yeah what a
transition what's the philosophy between
the peanut with the penis flashing
what's the philosophy of the Pina Colada
I did not wash my penis China there is a
difference right on the right that's
true on the comedy special use dudes fly
to China so don't get it twisted kid is
it can you just show people your penis
during a performance or is that
continued like consent um no I'm
actually in a lot of legal trouble right
now and this is my last interview before
I go to jail oh I'm sorry to hear that
oh you actually can you can AB nudity if
it's part of a performance this is a
conversation we get into with my lawyer
a lot of times foreigner condors show
but yeah that's why there's you could do
nude scenes in movies nude scenes and
plays right that sense is the mangina
considered nudity I don't know it's like
if someone does a mangina in the forest
it doesn't make a sound
it's like one of those questions does it
make a smell I feel like the main topic
as well yeah does it have any starch
right yes to both I would imagine a man
it's been a while since I may enjoy nod
ela have you ever seen a mangina in
person no I've only seen era Contras
that's the first mangina you've seen
well I'm kind of bitter about that Eric
you kind of this is my wife that you
gave her her first mangina I'm suing you
I am suing the school system I am suing
the teachers I am suing the principal
ela what was your reaction
mangina I was impressed impressed by the
people I guess I could do that
wait hold on Oh blue god oh hold on I
can do that
I guess it doesn't seem like it would be
so easy to do you just jam it back there
and slam right but you did it so fast
jam and slam I got a lot of experience
on the draw in the West well that's
something that all boys do if you didn't
know you look at every boy at a certain
age realize he could suck his dick good
balls back and have a vagina for a
minute yeah my dad was like why do you
always do this thing why don't you show
them your real penis man I got dad
that's a crazy thing to say I was like
I'm crazy but you know is there there's
really not a female a version of a
mangina unfortunately no there's the
there's the cosiness it's described that
you just got a beef up your labias oh
[ __ ]
stretch him out for Mom Gretchen stretch
of tape there was there was the next
season already shot over Kandra yeah
yeah we finished shooting right before
quarantine oh you are
what is your accent where are you from
that question daughter phaidor
la Dora fedora from generation from
generation to generation in Hebrew how
do you say it in Hebrew what he said
generational say it sounds like you're
speaking Spanish daughter my daughter
it's aunt EULA doughnut-dog door the
door feeling that door I think the lies
throwing us off I don't think that's a
huge room
I did it I did a show in Tel Aviv a year
and a half ago it was like one of the
best shows I did really it's awesome
that's awesome so
so height did you like they love you I
like Tel Aviv yeah tell views off
Facebook
and the people there it was I was there
for Passover Passover for mass but the
promoter is great the venue was great
I ate amazing food I had the best hummus
of my entire leg hummus yeah I got some
really good records I got really good
old 70 he was at Coverity funk but
compared it covers up oh this like the
famous is really old 70s funk band oh
let me look it up like see AV e r ET I
think is a cave there may be [ __ ]
awesome they call the Israeli Beatles
this is how famous they were in Israel
they did their last show in Israel they
did a free show cavalry wait ok yeah ok
ok AV ER et I found them cover it so
they did their last show in Israel but
by I could see in the reflection of the
window they see you in the reflection
you see a ghost I do I just worry about
cheese Jake just at the front door he
goes you just walked out the front door
we can edit we can blur her in the
window where she did not sign the
release cabarets yeah so they were such
a big deal in Israel they called them
the Israeli Beatles that when they
played their last show there was a
million people there of an Israel of
Greater Israel if you like take out the
West Bank and stuff there's a population
of 5 million so you have almost a
quarter of the population at their
concert they say the streets were empty
in Tel Aviv Wow
oh yeah they're cool I love them
one of the main singers is also a
comedian so they got this like goofy
vibe
epic what are some of the guests that
you have on the new season
can you tell yeah yeah I can tell uh
gosh I'm drawing a blank
I got Grimes I got little yachty I got
Toro y Moi I got um a lot of rappers
Freddie Gibbs trippy red
I got Liz O's on Anderson pack is on
Weird Al Yankovic whoo
Joe Joey badass Machine Gun Kelly a lot
a lot we got a lot of good people look
Keith Stanfield oh gosh can you can you
share with me I love your interviewing
techniques and I don't know how many
people are familiar with that you have a
very particular way of interviewing
people you turn up the heat as much as
possible well we just don't run the air
conditioning so it gets very very hot
yeah and I'm sure it does get very hot
with all the lights you your goal is to
make the interviewee as uncomfortable as
possible all right well I'm not
uncomfortable we're just trying to make
like a absurdist bizarre talk show and
get like a reaction other people mm-hmm
the what makes it so interesting you're
watching real celebrities cope with my
nonsense and they don't know who the
[ __ ] I am so moon I take them to the
moon is that true though I feel like
people know who you are at this point
maybe in the fur I think we purposely
like seek out celebs that not only don't
even know me but wouldn't really watch
Adult Swim mmm it was it was definitely
harder this year but we have some
tactics yeah so we have some secret
operation science make them not know too
much but even if they know me or they
have seen the show they don't know the
gags that are coming all right you know
when cockroaches start flying out of the
palm anyone's gonna definitely how those
tacos hitting joggers are good I want to
eat some
fruits and veggies I've been being real
bad it's my birthday it's been my
birthday week and I'm happy birthday
thank you very much
but it's already too healthy to
quarantine yeah you know what in the
quarantine you know what's an
interesting phenomenon I've noticed that
I've become lazier and more horrid just
reprehensible just eating disgusting
[ __ ] not exercising I'm stuck at home
I've got more time but I'm becoming more
lazy I have less energy she's like yeah
I've noticed
yeah she has yeah you know i yeah i got
back for the first few months I was
drinking every night and just beating
that garbage bag and then a month ago
after my girlfriend's birthday she was
like we shook hands were like what's up
no no booze for a month and then I just
started like exercising eating healthy
like trying to get back on track so I'm
gonna come crashing down this weekend
but I'm gonna get back on track Charlie
Blake not be you not have a dad bod you
know it's bad when the when you're the
girl in your life is like two you've got
to get your [ __ ] together because they
were she kept drinking she did he's like
you gotta get you sure - mm-hmm
but she does not have a dad bod I what
do you do for exercise Oh jump rope jog
lift weights
yeah jump rope jump rope fascinating can
you crisscross can you double skip you
got any tricks I don't think I getting
double skip I'll everybody get away with
like a criss cross or - that's pretty
good
I mean hey I'm not gonna hate on that
thanks how many hours of sleep again
every day well six days six days that's
good
I'm proud of you that's a good regular
schedule what time you wake up oh wow
early riser motivated whoo when do you
notice I get to wish like midnight and
when you get in bed what do you do you
put on the TV you watch suffer you just
go to sleep no no
Electronics in the room like she always
charges her phone in the room I try to
get her phone out of the room mm-hmm
no no electronics no school no screens
in bed no TV no iPad no iPhone no laptop
I try I don't always sometimes I fail
but try to not have screens in the
bedroom that's a good Paul I've heard
that's a really good policy for relaxing
bed I'm not good at that
but and when you wake up how often how
long before you retreat your phone
I wake up shrieking in terror
yeah I'm pretty bad I usually go right
to the phone but I sometimes when I'm
behaving I like I wake up a shower brush
my teeth you do bite one routine then
I'll meditate then I turn on the phone
and they coffee mmm how long you
meditate for 20 minutes before breakfast
20 minutes before dinner Wow Wow so you
actually have a routine Virginia and
what kind of meditation do you do
TM Transcendental Meditation as and what
I usually hear people say that I don't
know what other kinds of meditation
there are is there ones where they just
they're all pretty similar it's that
right it's not a drastic difference
between it's either like a TM where you
focus on a mantra a meaningless mantra
or the breath something that's like very
low stimulus that has little to no
meaning so that your brain has like a
resting post to kind of focus on and
then your brain starts to kind of space
out and thoughts good and bad kind of
drift in that's your body processing
stress your remaining mind processing
stress then you kind of you go back to
your mantra you go back to the breath
it's just a way it's just simply a way
to calm down your central nervous system
there's that or there's like I've done
like guided meditations or like Buddhist
meditations where you don't close your
eyes all the way you kind of keep them
open and they talk to you through like
appreciating your mother and everything
she did for you or you
your food and all the farmers that farm
the food and the trucks that drove the
food to the supermarket and the people
that I did like some kind of like guided
meditations that this Buddhist monastery
what I've been in Nepal but that's not
my typical but it's but they're all kind
of like just a way to like calm down
your nerves central nervous system and
if you miss a meditation session do you
feel it yeah for me it's like a hunger
like it's like I'm a little anxious in
the morning before work starts so I do a
meditation there and then like halfway
through the day that you know like you
know after lunch when you kind of start
to crash it's kind of like siesta time
mm-hmm so like like mid-afternoon you
kind of like have that slump of energy I
meditate in that slump and then I come
out of the meditation with like energy
for the next and uh do you do you wipe
or do you use a bidet I have a todo
Japanese toilet that's what's up you
made it bro sprays my boat oh do you
have one that dries your ass as well or
just spray it dries these sprays it it
dries it then it analyzes your waste and
sends that report to your doctor
it's probably just some dude who gets
off on looking at pictures of your [ __ ]
yeah there's some weird Japanese guy
jerking off at total Factory yeah that's
like a it's like a Chuck Berry
restaurant I got like GoPro cameras in
my toilet like filming my butthole being
awesome so do you a little bit let's
talk shop a little bit because I also
have the Toto do you use a drying
feature or do you find that it's not
very nice I don't I find it's like takes
a while yeah you know I kind of don't
like drying out my butthole mm-hmm it
takes a long time I wish that it was
just a little more high pressure yeah I
agree but sometimes I'll just sit there
for ten minutes my thighs will go
they'll start going to sleep and it's
kind of funny too because you just walk
by and you the bathroom is just like
over like almost fat it's a lot now what
why
I love it I do love it i I do use toilet
paper to finish it off are you good with
the bidet I do it also I do the big day
though then a wet wipe then a dry whoa
printed you then a little dryer then I
get up and I have the squatty potty so
my legs are elevated holy dude you are
passionate [ __ ] yeah oh yeah and do
you use the pulsating washing or just
the straight while saving pulsating and
oscillating I use it as well
you start pulse you and what the
oscillate died hybrid oh you do both at
once why waste time
why waste our and using water ever go up
your [ __ ]
no the I have like the cheaper model
downstairs and that one's like a dart to
the ass the one in my master bathroom is
a little bit more gentle so I find that
I find that when it really hits my my
[ __ ] like bullseye it just it just
there's like a you know that ride at
Universal Studios the flood ride no oh
you know you're stuck in a subway and it
starts flooding Oh Oh what it's the it's
the tour just a tour with the jaws and
everything anyway that's what my [ __ ]
feels like when I hit the bullseye and
it just that's a lot if you could get a
lot of water up there now and I'll be
stuck on the toilet [ __ ] out the
extra water weird that goes up what can
I do I avoid it but that's what happens
when you get a direct bullseye with a
capital B if you know what I mean so
okay great
so so fantastic do you have a hairy
[ __ ] yeah I'm not very good
heard you mmhmm yeah oh wow you are
really hairless that's beautiful
nothing except the mangina which I
actually have seen which is you know the
toughed yeah you know well my my you
should see my mom she's like Alec
Baldwin what does that mean exactly very
Airy my mom's the Jewish my mom was in
the Jewish one hmm you know do you take
Metamucil do you take anything to soften
your bowel movements um you know what
I'm glad you asked
no okay I read bowel movements my babble
must well perfect
they're like shiny brown eggs but if
that's true why are you using three
steps to the wiping process that seems
over killed a minute I just like the way
it feels right I like the I like the
confidence I enter like I start my day
very confident yeah I know what you mean
all right I'll be honest with you I used
to use baby wipes a lot I found out
they're very bad for the environment so
I stopped I get the em biodegradable
ones so they say that those are a lie
they say no there's no such thing as
biodegradable baby wipes what yeah yeah
they [ __ ] I thought I was I thought I
was getting me I thought I was getting
there yeah it'd be approved once we were
there too at one point and yeah everyone
told us well really what what turned the
tide for me was I I saw like sewage
officials being like yeah all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] think you know what sewage
monsters do you know what fatberg is Oh
Google fatberg it will change your life
bro Fatburger yeah so when people yeah
it's called a fatberg when people [ __ ]
and flush baby wipes down the toilet you
get these massive like clogged arteries
of our sewage system called fatbergs
which is just baby wipes and [ __ ] melded
into a giant [ __ ] blood and have to
go these people have to go down there
and like scuba suits for [ __ ] and just
scoop it out like a double bypass so
they don't break down once that's a lie
what you and trust me that's Devitt was
devastating to me
I'm so pleasurable mm-hmm but so I don't
they'll have a whole box of it that
someone bought before we learned that
and it's unopened I mean we used to
bright we used to buy bricks of those
like sad [ __ ] kilos of cocaine bro
and they come all packed like a kilo you
know what about what about the for
babies what do you do for an actual baby
well you're supposed to discard those
with the diaper so it's garbage
aha doesn't go in though yeah yeah yeah
yeah got it but I'll be honest with you
Eric that I've stopped using all wiping
I just using the bidet and every once in
a while I'll go down there and check to
see what's up with the baby wipes and
there's a lot of she'll be honest
there's a lot of [ __ ] my [ __ ]
sometimes
and his podcast took a horrendous turn
but I'm trying my best to keep it what
is the problem what is the premise of
this podcast
well it's shitty [ __ ] man Jonah's
and uh why is it called h3h3 we should
really turn roads and what is that stage
yeah I know
[Music]
no it's our art we have a we have a
channel on YouTube called a straight
reproductions it's just our initials ela
3 is my name backwards Ethan its they e
backwards it's lost really it's our lost
way we should just call the eath the the
we should really just call it poop and
mangina podcast yeah you'll get it
you'll get a whole new audience
I saw you wanna you were on Kimble
recently Jimbo Jimbo yeah Jimbo Campbell
isn't worried about Wendy's my favorite
Jimbo Jimbo please your Kimball is Jimmy
Cooper wendy is that uh yeah that's
Wendy's beatlejuice beatlejuice
no it's Wendy the slow doll she goes
general Campbell that a-hole
I thought well hold on Zach who is it
saying Jimbo Kimball it's Wendy the
sauce yes Wendy the slow dog what it
sounds just like her I can't go hit ball
I always lose
I miss beat man yeah why is he where is
he he's sick he's got like diabetes and
[ __ ] she's and Wendy the slow adult for
those who don't know she wears a diaper
and shits their pants so it all ties in
true Eric Andre is there anything that
you want to say to the world coming off
this spectacular riveting interview what
is it that you want the people to know
what did they want so we've set it all I
left it all out on the stage today yeah
I feel that way yeah you really don't
you don't trim your nose hairs do you
have ear hairs that you have to pluck
because I find myself your hair yeah I
mean that future might be coming for me
how old are you may I ask
I'm 37 okay you're you see I don't know
what happened I'm younger than you a
little bit but I've got these really
incredible your ear hairs that I just
have to pluck it's all right it's just
hereditary I think some of the black
squashed out some of the Jew right in me
so I didn't get some of the undesirable
Jewish traits the main one I got is just
your average crippling anxiety and
self-loathing scored scored with that
one I mean that's good but you don't
have that your ears your hairless my mom
my mom did the 23andme she was like
maybe I got some North African in me
hundred percent who's like the pie chart
hundred percent Ashkenazi Jew in bread
so I had the same test I did 23 me I was
ninety-nine point seven percent
Ashkenazi Jew I was like you
[ __ ]
not a single great-great-great grandpa
stepped out of some other tribe that's
an I'm the first I'm the first one in my
own lineage thousands of years the [ __ ]
anon to breed with a non Ashkenazi Jew
with a Sephardic Jew of some you know
they believe the Sephardic Jews are
second-class citizens in Israel or at
least they do that's crazy it's like
even among good a lot there's a little
bit I just find it incredible that like
among Jews who moved who are outcasts
from the world
to Israel even amongst themselves they
have seconds on that note the door of a
door the door dora the explorer all
right well you keep that household tight
and clean my friend
night-night keep your butthole tight yes
or not tight whatever you're into I need
even loose like a pink sock yeah you can
loosen it up but keep it clean one way
or the other are you going to fist Fest
this year [ __ ] you know what fist fest
is no it's a great Stern bit you should
listen it's when a bunch of dudes who
are into fisting all get together and go
elbow deep in each other's [ __ ] and
they prolapsed each other's penises I'm
gonna I'm actually I'm going to fat bird
fatberg fest yeah well you're there
already you're you're contributing to
fat burn yes I'll see you there my
friend yes sir well thank you for
calling in you're never there Phil is
out now legalized everything I'm very
much looking forward to all the projects
you're working on we're all fans we love
you very much so thank you for taking
the time to call our show god bless you
Eric Andre keep slamming your thing
keep eating tacos keep that bull hold
tight and clean keep keep the meditating
go and no screens in the bedroom
Gaby sounds good - thanks guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]